und wir wollen damit anfangen was
wahrscheinlich viertel nach acht in den
vergangenen Wochen Monaten geprägt hat
Nena nämlich der Frage was bei Corona
passiert das stimmt das hat viele nach
acht geprägt wie unsere gesamte
Gesellschaft aber vor allem treibt mich
die Frage um dürfen wir Menschen ihre
Existenzgrundlage nehmen vor Corona war
es eigentlich vollkommen klar was wir
darauf antworten würden nein natürlich
nicht wir können Menschen nicht ihre
Existenzgrundlage nehmen doch seit
Corona ist diese Frage eigentlich nur
mit Ja zu verantworten wir dürfen
Restaurants schließen Restaurants müssen
Banken Restaurants müssen dann zwei g
einführen wo sie natürlich auch eine
umsatzgruppe ausschließen und auch der
Einzelhandel verkauft aktuell viel viel
schlechter die Konsum Leidenschaft ist
nicht mehr da auch nicht mehr die
Leichtigkeit es gibt Umsatzeinbrüche ein
Hotelmanager hat mir erzählt er hat
stornierungen bis zu 70 Prozent die
Wirtschaft leidet wieder einmal wegen
Corona wegen der Pandemie und ich finde
wirklich dass wir das viel zu wenig in
der Gesellschaft besprechen denn
Lebensträume Existenzgrundlagen viele
Menschen wollen am Start abhängig
gemacht werden dementsprechend geht es
nicht nur darum dass die Hilfsgelder
jetzt verlängert wurden es geht vor
allem darum ob wir das als Gesellschaft
eigentlich dürfen und vor allem auch
nicht bald mal die Frage beantwortet
werden muss wie lange noch für mich ist
das Fazit eigentlich klar Corona ist für
unsere Gesundheit genauso unberechenbar
wie die corona-maßnahmen für unsere
Wirtschaft
du triffst ein ganz ganz wichtigen Punkt
und wenn man sich einmal die Kosten
anschaut die wir jetzt haben in dieser
Pandemie da muss man ja eigentlich von
zwei Arten von Kosten ausgehen einmal
von den Kosten die wir direkten messen
können das sind Kosten durch das
geschrumpfte Bruttoinlandsprodukt also
durch die Schließungen da sind bis
Sommer dieses Jahres ungefähr 300
Milliarden Euro gewesen diese ganze
Krise und die lockdowns gekostet haben
was hat das Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft errechnet und dann gibt es
natürlich noch Kosten die bei den
Behörden auflaufen Bundesagentur für
Arbeit beispielsweise 52 Milliarden für
Kurzarbeiter und so weiter und so fort
aber die andere Frage der Kosten ich
glaube das ist eine ganz entscheidende
die haben wir noch gar nicht gesehen das
sind die Kosten diese immateriellen
kosten die Kosten die entstehen wenn
Schüler nicht zur Schule gehen können
wenn sie im Homeoffice oder im
Homeschooling sind viel viel an Wissen
verlieren wenn Menschen krank werden
weil sie nicht arbeiten können
beispielsweise dann sind das Kosten und
sie sind Arzt Herr Wimmer von daher
wissen sie das sicherlich auch was
kosten die erst noch entstehen also ich
glaube wir haben es hier mit einer Krise
zu tun die die schlimmste seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg ist und zwar nicht nur
wegen der finanziellen Kosten sondern
auch der ganzen materiellen Kosten die
noch kommen so gefährlich als die
Kanzlerin zu Beginn der Pandemie von
öffnungsdiskussionsorgien sprach denn
als wir anfing früh zum Thema zu machen
wie können wir verantwortliche
öffnungsperspektiven entwickeln da wurde
das diffamiert dabei ist es aller Ehren
wert sich um die Existenzsorgen von
Menschen Gedanken zu machen um ihre
wirtschaftlichen Existenz Sorgen um
einsame Menschen oder auch um die Kinder
die nicht mit dem goldenen Löffel
aufwachsen und die wirklich große
Probleme haben und da haben wir am
Anfang so eine übermoralisierung gehabt
wo man diese ethischen Dilemmata diese
Zielkonflikte nicht ansprechen sollte
weil man dann gleich als unvorsichtigt
wir müssen eine Sache trennen weil wir
einerseits sozusagen über die
wirtschaftlichen Schäden sprechen und
die Schäden für Kinder ich glaube das
sind zwei unterschiedliche Themen lassen
wir uns mal bei der Frage jetzt bleiben
was das für die Wirtschaft bedeutet und
ich würde dem einmal widersprechen weil
sich alle so unterwegs sind allein
deshalb aus konzeptgründen eigentlich
die tatsächlich der Meinung die Frage
ist doch was wäre jetzt die Alternative
ich habe mit einem befreundeten Hotelier
ebenfalls gesprochen heute der in der
Tourismusregion arbeitet und der hat
heute entschieden und hat gesagt ich
mache mein Hotel nicht auf weil die
Buchungslage so schlecht ist weil er
nicht weiß was Weihnachten passiert was
Silvester passiert und er sagt ich kann
jetzt nicht Leute einstellen und sagen
weiß nicht was passiert das heißt und
diese Sicherheit und er sagt und er ist
eigentlich sehr glücklich dass es diese
Sicherheit diese Hilfen momentan gibt
weil er sagt dass das doch sozusagen den
Staat oder unseren Staat auszeichnet
dass wir für schlechte Zeiten sozusagen
gewappnet sind das ist das eine und das
andere ist was wäre tatsächlich die
Alternative zu sagen wir hätten diesen
Schutz dann unfassbar wichtigen Punkt
Paul der ist wirklich wichtig weil dein
Hotel je auch wenn es mir für jeden
Hotel in Deutschland leid tut die
Umsatzeinbrüche du machst keinen
wichtigen Punkt er trifft die
Entscheidung selbst dein Freund dein
Hotel sagt so für mich lohnt es sich
jetzt nicht mit den Mitarbeitern ich
mache zu die Angestellten aber auch von
deinem Hotelier haben nicht die Wahl die
Angestellten Modelle zum Beispiel
Entscheidung wir können die Arbeiten das
ist ja wie wie Traubenzucker für ein
Marathon wir können mal vorübergehend
kann der Staat mal Einkommen ersetzen in
der Krisensituation
am Ende ist es nämlich so deswegen der
Hotelier macht nicht auf weil es für ihn
sich nicht lohnt und weil es sich
offenbar für ihn mehr lohnt dass andere
den Lohn bezahlen für seine Mitarbeiter
ja alle ganz genau die Bundesagentur für
Arbeit macht 52 Milliarden an Kosten für
diese Krise genau und ich glaube das ist
das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt das
sind diese Schäden die zusätzlich die
Kosten muss man dann sagen 1A 1B die
einen Kosten über direkt sieht die
anderen die kommen zur sich und ich muss
trotzdem noch mal sagen ich fand den
Punkt den lindert heute Berg gemacht hat
eigentlich schon ganz richtig weil in
der Gesamtrechnung sind das
möglicherweise später auch Schäden die
unsere Wirtschaft betreffen wenn viele
Schüler nicht richtig lesen oder
schreiben können überspitzt formuliert
dann geht das genau da rein dass wir
sagen das Wachstum in künftigen Jahren
fällt geringer aus volkswirtschaftliche
Schäden jetzt kommt der Arzt aber auch
das sind Kosten
medizinisch mal sagen wir waren am
Anfang hinterher erstmal immer schlauer
ja wir waren am Anfang nicht so doll
aufgestellt wir haben noch Karneval äh
Saison erlebt da sind Leute als
Coronavirus gegangen weil sie es wird
sich fand und nicht ernst genommen haben
und ich habe ja nun in der ersten Stunde
gewarnt und wurde danach auch von den
Medien ziemlich runtergeschrieben wir
sind alle noch rumgelaufen wir haben
alle noch alles mögliche gemacht und das
Virus war voll da weil alle so getan
haben als müsste es über die
Seitenstraße nach Deutschland kommen es
war längst da es war längst da und
werden großes Glück dass wir es erkannt
haben und in dem Moment wir hatten keine
Masken wir hatten keinen Impfstoff also
will mal ganz locker bleiben und
überlegen damals war es das Richtige und
wir Deutschen sind nicht die agilsten
nicht die schnellsten manche sagen wir
sind wie ein Blech einmal gefüllt mit
Sand man kann sich nur ein Fuß brechen
wenn man gegen tritt also wir haben eine
Weile gebraucht nur genauso lang
brauchen wir dann auch um wieder neu
anzukommen und zu sagen jetzt geht
eigentlich wieder mehr und dann ist es
aber so ein kollektiven Gedächtnis nein
es darf das nicht und dann diffamieren
wir Nachbarn weil die sagen bei einer
Beerdigung kommen wir zwölf Leute
ansprechen also diese zwei g-geregelung
machen wir ja als Staat damit sich
Menschen impfen lassen drei Gewehre ja
da frage ich jetzt natürlich den Arzt
aber wäre mit Blick auf den
Gesundheitsschutz wäre ja auch 3G
möglich in Restaurants oder im
Einzelhandel vor allem in großen
Kaufhäusern da müsste man jetzt nicht
Zweige machen und da muss ich wirklich
sagen korrekt gemacht wird es werden
impfzertifikate gefälscht das heißt wir
haben schon mal bei 2G wissen wir gar
nicht ob alle 2G sind neulich habe ich
eine Veranstaltung gehabt da hieß es
jeder testet sich jetzt mal bitte und
ich stand und habe gesagt bitte testet
euch mal die meisten wussten gar nicht
wie so ein Test geht weg
der Impfpass kann genauso gefälscht sein
wie das Test da gibt's aber in großen
kaufen ist 3G möglich
dass das ist halt bitter für die
Wirtschaft und ich fühle damit ich habe
auch Angestellte und wir überlegen auch
wir können uns treffen ich habe auch
Busen gehabt ich hatte eine große Lesung
die war vorbereitet eine Tournee alles
abgesagt wir dürfen arbeiten so genau
ich darf Arbeiten ich arbeite auch aber
ich finde auch agile Wege und das
Problem ist oft dass man sich so ein
bisschen zurücklehnt und sagt er soll
mal der Start komme ich Zeit auch so
viel Steuern man muss schon ein bisschen
darauf achten und sich auch an die
Regeln halten ja und die Regeln jeder
guckt immer wieder drumherum kommt und
sieht aber immer bei dem anderen die
Fliege auf dem Tisch obwohl es zwar
einem selber schon wirklich was mich
interessiert wird heute backt sie als
Politikerin FDP-Politikerin ihre Partei
hat ja seit Regierungsübernahme da auch
einen ziemlichen Wandel durchgemacht
andere sagen
eine Wende hingelegt wie ist das wenn
man plötzlich als Partei mit in der
Regierung ist und jetzt diese
corona-politik die sie ja vorher massiv
kritisiert haben und ich würde mal die
Theorie aufstellen wenn sie noch in der
Opposition wären dann wäre die FDP jetzt
nicht für die Impfpflicht stimmt es
erstens ist gar nicht die FDP für die
Impfpflicht so ist es ja schon mal nicht
vorsichtig und auch viele Kollegen nicht
aber diskutieren Süßigkeit betont also
ganz konsequent und ich finde das ist
heute noch notwendig
so manche die einfach Lust haben an
starken Eingriffen ich finde wir dürfen
die Freiheit nur so viel wie unbedingt
notwendig aber so wenig wie möglich
einschränken und deshalb kann es mal in
einem Hotspot notwendig sein auch
Geschäfte schließen zu müssen also aber
das darf jetzt nicht sozusagen zum
Grundmuster werden genau deshalb haben
wir auch das Gesetz übrigens geändert
keine pauschalen lockdowns mehr sondern
wenn dann müssen übrigens auch die
Behörden und die Ministerpräsidenten
übrigens in ihren Ländern den Mumm haben
lokal oder in den Bundesländern
hat mich interessiert noch eine Sache
bei dem Thema Impfpflicht wie wird das
diskutiert jetzt in der FDP also da sind
plötzlich selbst Wolfgang Kubicki ist
plötzlich irgendwie für die Impfpflicht
zu halten hat man das Gefühl aber
Christian Lindner zumindest wie wie ist
da das Verhältnis bei der FDP und wie
diskutiert man das intern das ist ja
jetzt freigegeben worden dass alle
Abgeordneten so abstimmen können wie Sie
das sehen es wird gruppenanträge geben
und da wird man sehen sehen wir wie
abstimmt und es gibt sicherlich auch
abgestufte Vorstellungen aber ich bleibe
dabei dass ich meine allgemeine
Impfpflicht nicht vorstellen kann und
zwar obwohl ich sehr für das Impfen
werbe es gibt keine bessere Möglichkeit
dass wir auch ganz klar sagen ein
schweren kurvit 19 Verlauf zu vermeiden
und ich bin selber geimpft und werbe
dafür dass für erwachsene Menschen für
allermeisten das Richtige ist aber ich
bin davon überzeugt dass wir das nicht
sinnvoll durchsetzen können mit Zwang
wir müssen alles tun damit möglichst
viele Menschen sich zügig freiwillig
impfen lassen Freiwilligkeit Freiheit
ist ihr Thema was sie bewegt allerdings
ich glaube auch der Zug ist abgefahren
ich glaube der Zug ist tatsächlich
abgefahren überleiten auch das Thema von
heute-werk aber komm
also mein Bauchgefühl ist genauso wie
damals als ich gesagt habe dass das wird
ein Riesenproblem für uns werden und der
Gesundheitsminister saß und sagt er
reden sie mal nicht machen sie mal die
nicht die Leute verrückt wir haben so
lange diskutiert man sieht jetzt wie die
Infektion durchbrennt in gewissen
Regionen von Deutschland da brauche ich
danach eigentlich auch nicht mehr impfen
wenn Sie alle gehabt haben immer einfach
mit klaren Menschenverstand drauf gucken
wir diskutieren und diskutieren und
zeigen mit dem Finger auf alle und in
der Zeit das Coronavirus wartet ja nicht
so wie lange wie wir diskutieren und am
Ende werden es Leute sozusagen wenn
Recht behalten und sagen ja in Freiheit
steht über alles ja weil wir auch
einfach die Maßnahmen nie dann genutzt
haben wenn sie nutzen können beim Thema